hey guys it's Joe and I hear today's
workout it's all about working on your
calf muscles if you one long and lean
looking calves well do these exercises
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds rest in between if you
have a skipping rope well use this
because we want to work on skipping for
the first exercise okay so give your
best shot and really use your calf
muscles ready let's go so it's not about
hopping too high okay it's all about
keeping your legs straight and just
using your cows to lift your body up
that's it nice and easy get your body
warmed up this is also really good low
bar
good so point your toes lift your heels
off and just skill okay it's not about
going high remember it's all about
engaging your calf muscles keep going
very good keep skipping nice if you
don't have a skip you're up that's okay
just do it and imagine that you are
using a rope nice keep going few more
seconds and rest it up good now put your
rope aside we want to do in and out for
the second workout so it's all about
working on your cuffs so stand in a
closed position go out and in as fast as
you can okay
it's all about small movements on your
leg let's go out and in keep your upper
body as steady as possible just go out
and in so this is in and out steps good
keep going upper body as steady as
possible okay movements all coming from
your legs and your cuffs nice in and out
left and right
good find your coordination okay nice
look straight ahead
in and out and remember to breathe keep
your knees bent and
big step in and out okay fast big steps
keep going last few more and rest it up
good you should feel your calf muscles
working next exercise is going to be a
shuffle so again small but quick alright
so check it out let's shake your legs
out a little bit and let's go shuffle
forward and back so we worked on left
and right just now and now we want to
work on forward and back good so again
keep your body up and straight and
shuffle forward and back as fast as you
can and feel your calf muscles working
very good forward and back up about it
as steady and straight as you can so
chest up do not hunch or lean forward
good keep going let's speed it up ten
more seconds pull them back speed it up
shuffle good point your toes lift your
heels very nice keep going and rest it
out alright next exercise your favourite
squat jump okay so when it comes to
squat jump is all about pushing and
exploding to the top using your calf
muscles okay ready let's go down step up
explode with your cuffs good explode
land gently explode and then very good
so I wanted to really engage your house
focus and think about working on your
cuffs keep going bend your knees gently
cuffs very good push it higher up the
higher you go the more you will be
working on your cuffs up and down whoop
do your heart rate
it's also a really good cardio workout
up crew Shekhar's
push your butt back chest open point
your toes and land gently last one and
shake it hard
your legs should feel wobbly right now
what we want to work on calf raises okay
so single leg calf raises just balance
on one side let's start on all right
okay
so I want you to keep your right on the
floor and lift it off slightly just very
small movement heels off down here's off
and down good up and down that's it so
small controlled movement okay nice keep
going up and down up and down and now
let's swap change leg left side up and
down good tap gently up squeeze your
cuffs right at the top okay very good
squeeze it tap squeeze and tap squeeze
and tap right keep going few more find
your balance type in the core and rest
it out and the last workout I want you
to do is downward dog okay so grab your
mats you can have it later and give me a
nice downward dog and what I want to do
is the stretcher comes out in order to
lengthen your muscles that's it
walking dogs keep walking and keeping
your back flat
I want you to really feel your calf
stretching and lengthening it good so
this workout will really help to
lengthen your calf muscles very nice
lengthen it lengthen good and keep
walking keep going
nice feel the stretch in your calf
muscles feel it lengthening and that's
how we get toned and lean cuffs and a
fighter just hold it
press your calves down press your back
down and just real
through that deep stretch and just relax
rested a little bit one minute rest
and let's repeat the second set
[Music]
you have about 15 seconds rest okay we
want to move on to the second set so you
know all the workouts give me your best
effort again skip it's all about
focusing on your cuffs if you don't have
a rope that's okay
imagine a rope in your hands and let's
start now
good so it's not about going to happy
it's about working on your cuffs keeping
your feet together point your toes and
list your shoes okay find your rhythm
find your pennies very good
and breathe in and breathe out you're
not racing against anybody but yourself
okay so keep your wrist soft and just
find that rhythm listen to your inner
body listen to your inner rhythm good
keep going well
feel your calves burning very good whoo
the better you pace your breathing
the longer you will last through your
workout and good rested ah let's drop
that second workout in and out steps
okay again it's all about keeping your
upper body centered it's all about
working on your lower body and your calf
muscles fast steps all right let's go in
and out lateral right left and right
good step in and step out always keeping
your heels off the floor okay you're
always stepping on your toes
only good chest up look forward and step
like you mean it
keep going out and keep your knees bent
slightly very good in and out in and out
OOP he's your breathing I can feel you I
can feel your calves burning but let's
not stop now let's do the burn and let's
push through in a loud
left and right you got this left and
right stop
and rested on alright we've done left to
right and now we want to work on front
and back okay so shuffle as fast as you
can
keep your legs as straight as you can
with a slight bend in your knees ready
and let's go left right I'm in forward
and back point okay good
shuffle shuffle relax your shoulders
keep your shoulders soft and just let it
rock together good running back and just
allow your arms to swing gently front
and back as well good again
Hue's should always be lifted off and
you should be pointing on your toes good
let's speed it up last 15 seconds
let's go spit it up front back whoop I
wanna hear you say I'm on fire let's go
keep pushing last few more and rest very
good your favorite workout squat jump
again when it comes to squat jump it's
all about the mind engaging wreath of
the cuffs the more you consciously think
about your calf muscles the more you'll
work on it okay ready
let's go up up push with the cuffs
explode up with your cuffs good push it
land gently feel your butt working as
well keep your up keep your chest up
forward and push your butt back
very good so push up point up and point
keep going you are more than halfway
there
very good do the burn and feel it see
you sweat dripping keep going ten more
seconds push it up with the cuffs work
on those cuffs okay
we tend to neglect our calf muscles and
rest it out alright single leg calf
raises or if you wanted you can always
start with double leg calf raises okay
so look forward look straight ahead find
your balance
tighten your core and give me double leg
raises okay just up and down if you have
a stepper then of course you can use a
stepper alright to add a little bit more
challenge if this is too easy
find your balance and let's go to single
like half raise and keep going okay up
point a toast Lent and keep pointing
very good up and down and now let's
change to your left side woo by now you
should feel wobbly good up and down find
a balance tighten your core and get your
entire body to work on your calves good
feel that burn feel the muscle
contraction and rest it out alright good
one final calf stretches okay grab this
place it in the middle ready let's go
walking dog okay remember push your back
into the floor your heels into the floor
and walk it out good fill the left and
the right calf being stretched out good
keep walking keep pointing very good
feel it stretching feel that deep
stretch okay if you want you can even
hold it for two turns
hold it and keep walking
nice remember again keep your back flat
do not hunch good keep going and now
let's just keep both feet on the ground
and push it in feel the deep stretch in
your calf smoosh it in hold it down just
feel your cups and lengthening up
[Music]
and drop itself down and release so that
was six really effective cuff exercises
you can even treat this workout as your
cardio and even your warmup so it's all
about focusing and working on your cuffs
because that's the muscle retention you
glad okay so at this workout into your
routine do it as you warm up if you want
to or even annual workout with this
don't forget to like this video share
this video and check out a lot more
workout videos from my channel and also
recipes fitness tips and nutritional
tips all the best see you in the next
workout